heute gibt's management das ist eine
ganz traditionelle und typischer
eierspeise die wird noch mal so ein
bisschen getürmt mit tomate mit peperoni
und leckeren gewürzen und wie ihr euch
direkt was zeigen sich heute also kommt
mit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich kann ehrlich gesagt niemanden der
mir nicht mag und ich persönlich ich
gönne mir das viel zu selten merke ich
gerade aber mindestens dann wenn meine
eltern zu besuch sind zum frühstück dann
gibt's x men und das ist halt nicht so
typisch zum frühstück sondern ihr könnt
euch auch mal angst wenn du so ein
kleines mädchen habe machen stets ihr
direkt butter in einer pfanne und gäbe
da olivenöl mit dazu ich finde einfach
olivenöl gibt noch mal richtig guten
geschmack ihr könnt aber auch darauf
verzichten wenn ihr es gar nicht da habt
ein bisschen mit dazu dass wir das jetzt
erwärmen erhitzen auf stufe 6 von 9 und
gibt dann meine peperoni mit dazu die
habe ich vorab nämlich schon mal in
grobe stücke geschnitten und wird es
dann wirklich so vier bis fünf minuten
in der butter öl mischung andünsten
übrigens ist mein olivenöl aus palästina
nach einem jahr endlich wieder da ich
verlege euch das genauso wie alle ganz
genauen mengenangaben unten in die camps
in der infobox genau und während der
baronie vor sich hin brutzelt mache ich
weiter mit den tomaten die sind so
typische management ihr könnt jetzt es
gibt zwei varianten entweder über die
city toom also schwitzt die natürlich
vorher ein übergießt sie mit kochendem
wasser für fünf minuten dann schält sich
die haut quasi von alleine ab oder ihr
macht es euch noch einfacher und nehmt
euch hier eine reibe nehmen die tomate
einfach so wie sie ist und treibt sie
dann und was übrig bleibt also die
äußere hülle die brauchen nämlich die
macht nämlich einen komischen mund
geschmack hinterher
[Musik]
die tomaten gebe ich jetzt auch dazu und
da dürfte auch das komplette wasser was
da jetzt ausgetreten ist mit dazu geben
ich gehe es mit der stufe auch ein
bisschen höher auf die sieben oder sogar
acht von neun denn das darf jetzt ruhig
so ein bisschen einkochen und zwar für
so ungefähr sechs bis acht minuten ich
muss sagen ich mache das immer so nach
gefühl deshalb ist das erste mal das ist
wirklich so schritt für schritt erklären
aber so ein paar minütchen noch und dann
kommen die eier und die leckeren gewürze
dazu man merkte deutlich warum je nach
gefühl das
musste ein bisschen und so viel mehr und
so viel zucker und
[Musik]
jetzt kann man sehen dass die masse
deutlich weniger geworden ist und an der
stelle geben wir unsere eier mit dazu
das geld warum ich so vorab und so eine
schüssel aufgewühlt war einfach mit rein
und dann müsst ihr warten bis es ein
bisschen stockt das dauert jetzt auch
wieder wahrscheinlich so
2007 market analysis medien und danach
werden wir so ein bisschen leicht hin
und herschieben und ich würde sie jetzt
aber auch schon mal natürlich mit zwei
und bei mir komme ich gesagt nur drei
gewürze mir dazu weil alle anderen
zutaten sprechen so ein bisschen für
sich so was ganz wichtig ist typisch
türkisch ist
polizist
paprikapulver aber ein bisschen anders
ein bisschen grüner
paprika flocken genau
sieht auch direkt richtig gut aus mit
der farbe und was bei mir nicht fehlen
darf ist oregano also wirklich nur diese
drei gewürze und das war's so ungleich
wie gesagt nur noch ein bisschen hin und
her schieben und dann könnt ihr euch das
am besten mit pj dell mit brot einfach
schlitz
[Musik]
unser menge wenn es fertig entweder
könnt ihr das direkt in der pfanne
servieren dann einfach zack den griff
abnehmen das gute daran ist in der
pfanne webwelt viel viel länger warm ist
allgemein fand so dass die sehr sehr
sehr lange warm werden die speisen aber
auch fürs türkische feeling habe ich mir
jetzt meine kupfer fahne genommen die
linke ich euch auch gerne in den box das
coole ist nämlich wenn ihr gas habt oder
türrahmen genau dann könnt ihr damit
auch direkt auf eurem kochfeld kochen
mit dem kupfer fan aber ich habe
induktions der typischen eben jetzt
kommt mir eigentlich direkt der gruppe
von genau direkt in der kurve verloren
und auf feuer das wäre dann so richtig
typisch türkisch genau wir lassen uns
das jetzt schmecken machen möchte
danke für die erinnerung ganz ehrlich
pröpstin raus dann werde der kamera so
sehr unauffällig petersilie noch mal um
auch sie zu schön
[Musik]
du hast jetzt folgendes gebaut wo warst
du es mir tun vor allem so arabisches
pro jahr balance toastbrot das hast du
gar nicht jetzt spiegel
das war bereit
mit der mp tec im militär über einkauf
hat das vergessen naja ist aber guck mal
ganz ehrlich tria hab ich sehr oft tosic
ist weil er kein arabisches prototyp
klima hatten ja und ich hab mich
geärgert weil du ist das sehr viel brot
also dickinson weil damals arabisches
motive so viel weniger ist vom ja weil
es so luftig ersten tipp würdest also
man hat viel mehr ein teilweises brot
eingehen weil sie da gemacht habe schon
mal das gemacht so der landwirt kann
doch mal was genau war der rand ist das
besser so eine einfache speise für die
einfachsten dinge sind manchmal echt die
leckersten ist noch viel fahren und dann
nicht gut nach verfahren wenn man will
man ich finde also für mich persönlich
muss kein treffen geben wir nur die welt
ja ich habe frau christa wohl
auch weil er so oft in istanbul haben
immer gut tun gemacht sie könnt ihr euch
mal in den box verlinken übrigens müssen
dieses kulturschock bekommen es ist ganz
normal ist meine tante ist ja so ja
stimmt gerade auch in meiner kultur ist
eigentlich alles mit hand ja ich habe
darüber nachgedacht oder muss ist mir
auch so die quadrant das stimmt mund in
indien ist nie so gareis per hand ich
war ja mal in diese fähigkeiten haben
nämlich auch reis gegessen also es gibt
bei mir alles runter fall noch teilweise
also was sagen wir jetzt noch es noch
jemanden grüßen oder gar nicht sein aber
nur ist
deutlich mit für unsere partner hunger
wir machen gerade übrigens auch noch
kommt also türkische kartoffeln im
backofen das rezept ich möchte da folgt
noch nicht ob das kommt endlich
tatsächlich optik doch das rezept ich
bin heute verwöhnt ja bis zum nächsten
sketch in jeans
[Musik]
[Applaus]